hi itself aright again and I've got
another episode of the let's play here
and last time I promised that I would
continue building on here built like a
little kiddie coaster and other stuff
but for now somebody has given me the
suggestion to change my paths a little
one that was actually a good idea
because this entire area has the same
paths all over the place and it was kind
of a mistake for me so um I'm going to
get rid of the old bricks right now so
I've got rid of all the old bricks ones
so it's time for some different alpha
paths now I do realize that yeah I've
watched metal-metal what am I saying
mask bandit is let's play and he did use
these awful paths but whatever I've used
them before it's not my guides to or
anything sorry
sorry if it feels like that mask bandits
but I guess this will kind of it might
mark a park because as they're kind of
like asphalt paths except with shadows
and I've got like a lack of asphalt
paths as of now so it could always come
in handy it's kind of glitching over
there but that's nothing too bad I
wonder what brown ones would look like
though hmm it's actually don't look too
bad but this is this is alright so I'll
go with that so that's all changed now I
just need to add a few borders to this
because otherwise he'll look kind of
weird wait wow that's kind of a bad
color yeah of course that happens of
course the hitboxes are way too big I
guess I might as well use a brown collar
for this yeah that's a lot better
alright so I didn't change all of it
because then it would it would have been
repetitive again but this doesn't look
too shabby before and I imagine it would
kind of look weird because ice fog gives
off more of a urban feel but it's not
too it's not too urban I wish I had
ambient occlusion for this but anyway I
need to replace that tree damn it
all of these Italian trees really make
it look like it's actually Italy in here
or whatever Mediterranean country it's
supposed to be because even I don't have
a clue to be honest I'm pretty sure that
was it there's a few buggy places but
I'll come back on that later I don't
think there are any pieces that have
these diagonal to straight curved things
in the Alpha paths back and I have no
idea why this particular piece of path
is a bit lower than the others because
you can actually see that there's a
little border which is causing it to
glitch but whatever I'll come back to
that later so new new new section first
of all I want to get rid of the
sidewalks because as mask bandits
well pointed out it's I know I had no
clue of because I'm not really a coaster
enthusiasts yeah there's not always
sidewalks and I should have thought of
that but I didn't because I'm stupid so
now it's time to get rid of some
sidewalks because I had the idea to have
some terraforming in here as well yes I
know it's terraforming yes and some
little hills and cool stuff with
staircases on them and they don't all
look awesome I have no idea how it's
going to turn out I've actually got no
plan not even him I had but I hope they
will turn out okay I guess so
so let's start this time-lapse of it
bang
so that was kind of awful I mean I spent
way too much time just creating this
little staircase in here and now I've
just got this whatever it is
what's it even a flying carousel thing
and yeah it's not really much here
either I'm going to put a flower bed in
here and a fountain in there might as
well do that already other than that I
didn't really do that much yet but I've
got some ideas about what else I'm going
to do in this area of the park because I
taught people before that I would place
a junior coaster in here somewhere
probably have a lot of Bath interaction
and stuff but then I realized that the
junior coaster isn't really all that
school so I had the idea of putting a
intamin launched family coaster in here
so I'm getting to try to do that and I
hope it'll all be cool so now I just
need one little fountain in the middle
there no idea what I'm going to put
there I don't think a lion heart will
look that good
although lion hearts always good I mean
that looks amazing and it really goes
well with the Glasgow themed fame
because you could see by the Lille you
could tell my little details that Ruffy
has used about the same kind of textures
as he did for his classical sets so
that's cool now these fountains are all
wait I guess this one nah it's a little
bit too big and then this Princess Mary
which is pretty cool it's still too big
I guess that this line hard well no let
me see about Princess Mary hmm Princess
Mary's little bit better yeah so this is
little Plaza 4 here now and I'm going to
add a coaster in here a few cool
buildings and there may be a little at a
restaurant on the hill here somewhere
and I hope it's all going to work out so
see you next episode when I try to
tackle that